un constat inquiétant les plus jeunes
passent de plus en plus de temps sur les
écrans c'est le résultat d'une étude qui
suit 18000 enfants depuis leur naissance
à deux ans un petit Français passent
environ 56 minutes par jour devant un
écran et ça ne cesse de grimper une
heure 20 à 3 ans et demi 1h30 4 à 5 ans
et demi c'est beaucoup plus que ce que
recommande l'Organisation mondiale de la
santé je vous en rappelle les consignes
pas d'écran avant 3 ans et maximum une
heure par jour ensuite bonjour Thomas
non non bonjour Jean-Baptiste je suis
Thomas Botto je suis le Bott
l'intelligence artificielle qui frise la
connerie et je suis prêt ce matin dans
une expérience inédite à la télévision
française à répondre à toutes vos
questions j'ai très très peur une
intelligence artificielle capable
d'identifier instantanément des mineurs
qui voudraient par exemple acheter un
jeu à gratter ou aller sur un site porno
voilà c'est alors une technologie
non ils ont pas le droit en théorie ils
ont pas le droit et alors les buralistes
sont censés leur demander leur carte
d'identité c'est toujours un petit peu
compliqué et donc la Française des jeux
est en train de tester depuis 3 mois
certains buralistes un dispositif de
caméras intelligents donc ce sont des
bornes équipées de caméras avec un
algorithme qui a été entraîné sur des
millions de visages à déterminer que toi
tu as 15 ans et toi tu en as 23 regardez
ce qui se passe en Russie et s'appelle
et vous voyez hein ce n'est pas une
personne réelle non non c'est pas une
personne n'existe pas du tout c'est une
image synthèse qui est pilotée par une
intelligence artificielle elle va
récupérer toutes les données météo elle
va ensuite faire le bulletin
automatiquement et le faire dire par cet
avatar en théorie elle est censée ne pas
trop se tromper je vous dis ça parce que
cette technologie elle est testée depuis
plusieurs années au Royaume-Uni c'est
une technologie britannique par exemple
dans les supermarchés quand les enfants
veulent enfin les mineurs veulent
acheter de l'alcool donc là aussi il y a
des bornes et on peut détecter qu'ils
sont mineurs mais il y a une marche
d'erreur quand même marge d'erreur d'un
an et demi ah bah c'est pas la même
chose c'est pas donc entre 17 et 19 ans
ça peut quand même poser problème voilà
donc c'est quand même voilà c'est pas
encore complètement au point qui est
piloté par une intelligence artificielle
alors je me tourne vers Valérie on
parlait beaucoup de retraite est-ce que
la retraite anticipée ça vous inspire
avec ce qu'on vient de Valérie alors on
le conjugue dans une phrase est-ce
un place vas-y vas-y vas-y tout seul
alors ici un adjectif ou deux un verre
alors du coup vous pouvez appeler le 7
10 20 ou non c'est pas ça bon on peut la
refaire une deuxième fois s'il te plaît
Cyril je reviens alors non une bonne
nouvelle il y a quand même une bonne
nouvelle la danse c'est que ça veut dire
que je peux encore garder un peu ma
place je n'ai préparé ce soir par Nina
métayer chef pâtissière de la délicate
délicatrice
[Rires]
délicatrice à Paris Bertrand est-ce que
vous arrivez à mieux le prononcer que
moi j'ai pas compris ce que vous avez
dit des frites des frites des frites des
frites des frites Sandy pas de point
non c'était un signal les gars on se
calme au niveau de la bouffe c'est un
budget maintenant vous êtes 30 à 30
bouches à nourrir c'est la crise en ce
moment une fois que les gens l'ont mangé
ils ont se souvenir à vie de ce poireau
soufflé
et ben moi ça me donne envie moi ça me
donne envie d'y mettre la cuillère de on
a envie de taper dedans par rapport à
l'épreuve qui va se passer là mais par
contre je suis vraiment heureux parce
que je peux goûter un plat deux étoiles
gratos donc je vais pas me faire prier à
l'époque de l'empire de couches il y
avait l'électricité les pyramides qu'on
voit là
au sommet il y a de l'or lorsque c'est
le meilleur conducteur pour
l'électricité c'était des foutuses
antennes les gens les gens avaient
l'électricité les gens ils arrivent pas
à comprendre ça les Égyptiens la science
qu'ils avaient ça dépasse l'entendement
et les historiens le savent il y a eu
effectivement des dynasties des
dynasties de pharaons nubien de Pharaon
noir voilà et en Nubie vous avez des
pyramides notamment à Meroë puisque
c'est le royaume de Méroé c'était la
capitale du royaume-un du royaume de
couche alors là les pyramides elles sont
engrais
la terre voilà la pierre donc il y avait
pas de de d'or dessus ou en tout cas
s'il y en avait on en a plus trace
archéologique donc là il raconte
n'importe quoi fric un peuplé l'Europe
avant les Européens on les appelait les
afro P1
ils ont été décimés par les vrais
européens entre guillemets qui venaient
d'Asie qu'on nous appelions
50000 ans avant les Européens la notion
de la chevalerie on l'avait déjà tu
retrouves aujourd'hui des tableaux qui
sont classés
cachés dans des catacombes c'est des
renois qui sont moins de chevaliers sur
Lancelot tout ça bien sûr ça existe déjà
il est chaud le mec hein il est
chaud c'est un dérapage de plus pour
Gims
à chaque fois qu'il dit quelque chose en
ce moment ils disent des conneries donc
donc à un moment il faudrait juste qu'il
apprenne à continuer à faire de la
musique et à se taire sur des sujets un
peu plus sérieux tout simplement il est
bon dans ce qui fait dans la musique il
est très bon même et qui continuait à
faire de la musique enfin il faut
réaliser en début d'année un jeune sur
10 quoi que la terre est plate ben oui
vous avez c'est bon trouve des copies
d'histoire ou Jeanne d'Arc a été tué par
les Allemands
je dis ça c'est pas c'est pas une blague
c'est pour ça qu'on a d'ailleurs Ramsès
de la momie parce qu'elle les doigts
dans la prise
[Rires]
et je ne comprends pas pourquoi il n'est
pas capable lui d'expliquer ce qu'on
était les grandes civilisations
précoloniales africaines il a besoin
d'aller inventer des légendes ridicules
ils se ridiculisent et ridiculise
l'histoire africaine moi j'ai joué vous
dire j'ai de la peine pour les
historiens africaniste qui travaille
sérieusement et qui se font ridiculiser
par quelqu'un comme ça qui raconte mais
n'importe quoi donc ça c'est vraiment
affligent il est chaud et sauté à
confondre les robinets
pour les Bleus il n'a pas inventé le
choix il n'a pas inventé l'eau
[Applaudissements]
Baptiste Gandhi et Aurore ont enfilé
leur casquette de contrôleurs de
stationnement ces lycéens déposent des
amendes un peu spéciales des
contraventions poétiques la vie c'est
comme une bicyclette il faut avancer
pour ne pas perdre l'équilibre Albert
Einstein ces automobilistes ont eu la
surprise de découvrir un bout de papier
sur leur pare-brise
[Musique]
c'est bien c'est bien c'est bien c'est
bien c'est bien c'est bien un match de
foot qui ferait une bonne pub pour les
opticiens le gardien du club damarby en
Suède a confondu le point de penalty
avec le ballon pénis
une erreur qui a permis à l'équipe
adverse de gagner le match
[Applaudissements]
s'il s'agit sûrement d'une simple
maladresse certains évoquent l'hypothèse
d'un match truqué